Ciao, mi chiamo Olivia Lanes e bentornato a Quantum Computing in Practice. Questo è l'episodio due:
quantum circuit. Copriremo diversi argomenti nella lezione di oggi, ma quello che voglio che tu porti via sono le seguenti tre cose: uno, cosa sono
davvero i computer quantistici IBM, così che tu abbia almeno un'immagine approssimativa in mente di cosa stai facendo quando invii un job a uno di quelli tramite
cloud. Due, cos'è Qiskit, cosa sono le Primitive e come possiamo usarle per creare ed eseguire quantum circuit.
Discuteremo anche ad alto livello i diversi tipi di processori IBM Quantum disponibili e cosa distingue l'uno dall'altro. E tre,
infine, il tipico flusso di lavoro che seguiamo per eseguire esperimenti su larga scala. Questo include la selezione delle migliori Primitive
per il tuo caso d'uso, il mapping di un problema su un quantum circuit e l'applicazione di soppressione e mitigazione degli errori, che ci permettono
di sfruttare al massimo queste macchine. Ora, c'è molte informazioni qui, ma continua a seguirmi
perché presto metteremo tutto insieme nel contesto di alcuni esempi reali. Prima, parliamo brevemente dei qubit e dell'hardware
quantistico vero e proprio. Come sperimentatrice, posso prometterti che è affascinante e aiuta davvero a collegare i puntini
visualizzare ciò che accade realmente quando i job vengono inviati a un computer quantistico tramite cloud. I processori che
useremo sono costruiti con qubit transmon superconduttori. Ecco come appare un piccolo processore IBM Quantum:
ora questi piccoli quadrati qui sono i qubit stessi, quindi ce ne sono in totale cinque su questo chip. Il transmon
stesso è un condensatore ed è costituito da due piastre di metallo collegate in parallelo con un induttore non lineare chiamato
giunzione Josephson. Ma per vedere la giunzione Josephson devi effettivamente ingrandire ulteriormente: è creata da due
strati sovrapposti di metallo superconduttore e dove i due pezzi si sovrappongono e si toccano è la giunzione. Una giunzione
Josephson è un elemento che può essere usato per creare un atomo artificiale con livelli di energia multipli e isoliamo
i due livelli energetici inferiori come nostro stato qubit. Le linee sinuose qui rappresentano i risonatori a microonde,
sostanzialmente linee di trasmissione 2D accoppiate al qubit. Ora quando programmiamo un gate, questo equivale essenzialmente a scegliere un
impulso a microonde altamente calibrato e la frequenza, l'ampiezza, la forma e la durata specifiche di quegli impulsi fanno fare
al qubit cose specifiche. Le istruzioni per l'impulso a microonde vanno dal tuo computer al cloud e
vengono poi lette e interpretate dall'elettronica di controllo a temperatura ambiente che prende quelle istruzioni e fisicamente
genera gli impulsi. Li chiamiamo impulsi a microonde perché rientrano tutti nella larghezza di banda di frequenza dei microonde,
che è intorno a 1 GHz. Dopo che le scatole di controllo a temperatura ambiente creano gli impulsi, viaggiano attraverso i cavi
nel refrigeratore a diluizione e infine al nostro chip quantistico. Il segnale entra nei risonatori attraverso
un wire bond su questi pad e poi scorre lungo la linea di trasmissione nei nostri qubit. Ora so che tutto questo potrebbe
essere sembrato un po' tecnico e questi dettagli non sono cruciali da capire per andare avanti, ma spero che ora tu
possa almeno immaginare il sistema fisico con cui stai per interagire. Quindi dove esistono questi computer quantistici?
Bene, IBM ha dozzine di computer quantistici in tutto il mondo e abbiamo recentemente aggiornato la nostra flotta per
contenere solo processori con più di 100 qubit. Come ho menzionato nella lezione precedente, alcuni si trovano in un
data center IBM Quantum nello stato di New York. Quei sistemi sono distribuiti nel cloud per l'uso di tutti e alcuni
sono sistemi dedicati on-premise completi di tutta l'elettronica necessaria per farli funzionare, a supporto dei nostri partner
nella rete IBM Quantum. Ora parliamo di Qiskit, che è il kit di sviluppo software open-source di IBM
progettato per lavorare sui computer quantistici. D'ora in poi mi riferirò a questo come Qiskit SDK. C'è anche l'ecosistema
Qiskit, che è una raccolta di software, tutorial e funzioni che si basano o estendono le funzionalità principali di Qiskit, nonché il
Qiskit Runtime, che è un servizio di quantum computing e un modello di programmazione che consente agli utenti di progettare ed eseguire in modo efficiente
i loro carichi di lavoro quantistici usando le Primitive di Qiskit. Una Primitiva è fondamentalmente un piccolo blocco costruttivo che
puoi usare per progettare circuit più grandi o un job. Le due Primitive più importanti per noi saranno il
sampler e l'estimator, che discuteremo più in dettaglio a breve. Se non hai ancora scaricato e installato il
Qiskit SDK, non c'è momento migliore del presente. Qiskit 1.0 è stato rilasciato di recente ed è più performante e
stabile che mai. Quindi per coloro che stanno iniziando, siete arrivati nel momento perfetto. Per coloro che
hanno già familiarità con Qiskit, dovrete scaricare e reinstallare la versione più recente. Raccomandiamo di usare
pip per installare Qiskit e Qiskit Runtime e di eseguirli tramite un Jupyter notebook in un browser web di vostra scelta. Quindi avrai anche bisogno
di installare Jupyter notebook o JupyterLab nel caso non lo avessi ancora fatto. Questi strumenti sono tutti gratuiti e puoi
installarli sulla tua macchina locale senza alcun costo. Assicurati di aggiungere Qiskit con le dipendenze dell'opzione
di visualizzazione in modo che funzioni con Jupyter e ti permetta di tracciare grafici. Dovrai anche configurare un ambiente virtuale Python e ci sono
istruzioni su come farlo nella pagina di installazione di Qiskit collegata qui. Una volta che hai familiarità con Qiskit e sei
pronto a eseguire job su veri computer quantistici, dovrai registrarti su quantum.com e creare un token
API IBM Quantum. C'è anche un link qui per questo. Per una guida dettagliata su come farlo, segui tutte le
istruzioni nella nostra pagina di documentazione come ho menzionato, oppure puoi guardare il video di installazione di Coding with Qiskit qui.
Entrambi sono collegati nella descrizione. Ora siamo quasi pronti per iniziare a parlare dei quantum
circuit. Poiché lo scopo di questo corso è insegnarti, al pubblico, come scalare i tuoi job per essere eseguiti a
scala di 100 o più qubit, credo che il modo più costruttivo sia considerare prima il flusso di lavoro complessivo che seguiremo. Il modo più semplice per
capire un tipico flusso di lavoro di quantum computing è attraverso i Qiskit patterns. I Qiskit patterns sono un framework concettuale che consente agli utenti di eseguire
carichi di lavoro quantistici implementando certi passi con strumenti modulari. Questo consente che i task di quantum computing vengano eseguiti da
un'infrastruttura di computing eterogenea potente. Questi passi possono essere eseguiti come servizio e possono
incorporare la gestione delle risorse, che consente la componibilità senza soluzione di continuità di nuove capacità man mano che vengono sviluppate. Ecco
i passi principali che gli utenti Qiskit esperti probabilmente già riconoscono. Il primo passo è il mapping. Questo passo
formalizza come prendiamo un problema generale a cui siamo interessati e capiamo come mapparlo in un computer quantistico
sotto forma di circuit. Poi ottimizziamo: in questo passo usiamo il Qiskit transpiler per instradare e disporre il
circuit su un vero hardware quantistico fisico. Questo include la traduzione dei singoli gate quantistici in sequenze
WEBVTT
di operazioni eseguite sull'hardware, nonché l'ottimizzazione del layout di quei gate. Poi
eseguiamo: le Primitive di Qiskit Runtime forniscono l'interfaccia all'hardware IBM Quantum che consente al circuit transpilato di essere eseguito.
Questo passo include anche l'uso di tecniche di soppressione e mitigazione degli errori, che possono essere in gran parte astratte via dall'utente. Infine, facciamo il postprocessing:
in questo passo, i dati del processore quantistico stesso vengono elaborati, fornendo all'utente risultati utili sul problema originale. In pratica, questo passo
comprende qualsiasi ulteriore analisi dei dati acquisiti. Ora siamo pronti a discutere le fondamenta dei
programmi quantistici, che sono i quantum circuit. Speriamo che tu abbia già familiarità con i quantum circuit, ma nel caso non lo fossi, potresti voler prima consultare la lezione
tre, Quantum Circuits, che fa parte di "Understanding Quantum Information and Computation" collegata qui sotto. Faremo solo
un breve ripasso qui. Ora, un quantum circuit è una rete di gate quantistici e misurazioni collegati
da fili che rappresentano i qubit. I quantum circuit possono essere letti come uno spartito musicale, da sinistra a destra, a partire dal
tempo zero, che si trova tutto a sinistra. I qubit virtuali, ovvero qubit che non sono ancora stati assegnati a un vero
qubit fisico su un processore, sono elencati in ordine crescente dall'alto verso il basso. Una volta configurato il nostro circuit, possiamo aggiungere
gate. I gate a singolo qubit come questo gate Hadamard qui influenzano solo il qubit sul cui filo sono posizionati. I gate a più qubit
come questo CNOT influenzano due o più qubit collegati dal gate. In questo esempio, lo stato del qubit uno cambia
a seconda dello stato del qubit zero. Dopo che tutti i gate sono stati applicati, possiamo eseguire misurazioni
che causano la scrittura dei risultati sui registri classici. Una caratteristica particolarmente importante di
un circuit è la sua profondità. La profondità del quantum circuit è il numero minimo di strati di gate quantistici eseguiti in
parallelo necessari per completare il calcolo definito dal circuit. Per essere chiari, i gate quantistici possono essere eseguiti in
parallelo, o in altre parole, nello stesso esatto momento, ogni volta che non hanno qubit in comune. Ma se due o più
gate agiscono sugli stessi qubit, non possiamo eseguirli in parallelo e siamo costretti a eseguirli uno dopo l'altro. Poiché i gate quantistici richiedono tempo per essere
implementati, la profondità di un circuit corrisponde approssimativamente al tempo necessario ai computer quantistici per eseguire il
circuit. Quindi conoscere la profondità di un circuit è importante per sapere se può essere usato su un particolare dispositivo oppure no. Ci dirà anche se
ha buone probabilità di produrre un risultato accurato. Passiamo ora alla selezione di un processore quantistico. IBM
ha recentemente rilasciato un'intera nuova flotta di processori, tutti con oltre 100 qubit, e puoi accedere a quantum.com per vedere
a quali processori hai accesso. I processori sono tutti nominati dopo uccelli per qualche ragione e i diversi loghi
rappresentano diversi tipi di processori. Quindi per esempio, questi rappresentano processori Eagle e questa icona è un
Heron. Il nome dei processori specifici si trova anche in cima: sono tutti nominati dopo città, ma questo
non significa necessariamente che il processore si trovi fisicamente in quella città. Sono solo nomi. Il conteggio dei qubit,
EPLG e CLOPS sono anche fattori elencati. Esamineremo ciascuno di questi.
Qubit: ora, questo è abbastanza autoesplicativo. Qubit è semplicemente il numero totale di qubit disponibili su quel singolo processore quantistico o
QPU. EPLG sta per errors per layered gate, che misura l'errore medio del processo del gate in una catena a strati di
100 qubit. In pratica, vuoi che sia il più piccolo possibile. CLOPS sta per circuit layer operations per second e
misura quanti strati di un quantum volume circuit, che è un circuit virtuale, una QPU può eseguire per unità di tempo.
Più alto è il numero, più velocemente possiamo calcolare. Questo equivale a ciò che significa FLOPS nel computing classico. Ora, queste
diverse metriche possono essere più o meno importanti a seconda dell'area applicativa specifica a cui sei interessato. Passiamo ora a discutere ad alto livello
il mapping ai quantum circuit. Il primo passo è il passo di mapping, che risponde essenzialmente alla domanda: come
traduco il mio problema in un quantum circuit che può essere eseguito sull'hardware quantistico? Ora, non c'è dubbio:
il mapping è un problema difficile ed è un'area di ricerca attiva. A volte solo essere in grado di prendere un problema
computazionale e trovare una sequenza di gate quantistici che aiuti a risolverlo è la parte più difficile. Non c'è un metodo infallibile
che garantisce il successo, ma ci sono linee guida raccomandate ed esempi di problemi che sappiamo già come
mappare. La prima linea guida è lasciare che i computer classici facciano da soli qualsiasi lavoro in cui sono più bravi. I test
facili per i computer classici probabilmente non trarranno vantaggio da un computer quantistico. I computer quantistici sono per problemi difficili da risolvere classicamente.
Naturalmente, se è la tua prima volta a usare Qiskit o un computer quantistico, non preoccuparti di trovare un problema computazionalmente complesso. Scomponilo
in problemi più piccoli che puoi imparare ad affrontare prima di passare direttamente a un progetto su scala utility. Poi, traduci i
risultati del tuo problema che vuoi misurare o comprendere in un problema di valore di aspettativa o di campionamento.
Per la maggior parte dei tipi di problemi, questo corrisponde essenzialmente al calcolo di una funzione di costo. Una funzione di costo è una
funzione specifica del problema che definisce l'obiettivo del problema come qualcosa da minimizzare o massimizzare, e possono essere
usate per vedere quanto bene uno stato o una soluzione di prova stia performando rispetto a quell'obiettivo.
Questa nozione può essere applicata a varie applicazioni in chimica, machine learning, finanza, ottimizzazione e così via.
Tieni anche presente che l'hardware che userai ha una topologia specifica. Alcuni qubit non sono connessi,
altri sì, e alla fine dovrai mappare il tuo problema su un circuit che rappresenta questo. I processori IBM Quantum
usano quella che viene chiamata una topologia heavy hex, che equivale essenzialmente a connessioni di qubit in un reticolo esagonale, di cui
parleremo più avanti nel corso. Per ora, la cosa più importante da tenere a mente è che questa fase richiede
pratica. Devi avere una buona comprensione non solo del tuo problema, ma anche delle
capacità dell'hardware quantistico, e vedremo un esempio specifico e un caso d'uso più avanti per vedere come questi possono essere al meglio
bilanciati. Ora parliamo di come ottimizzare un circuit per l'hardware che abbiamo selezionato. L'obiettivo generale del
passo di ottimizzazione è mappare tutti i qubit virtuali del nostro circuit a qubit reali effettivi da qualche parte nella
topologia del processore. Il nome del gioco è ridurre gli errori il più possibile. Per farlo, dobbiamo prima
instradare e disporre il nostro circuit in modo efficiente. La prima cosa da tenere a mente è che non tutti i qubit sono connessi, come
ho già detto. Alcuni sono effettivamente lontani l'uno dall'altro sul chip, quindi dobbiamo ridurre o eliminare le interazioni a
lunga distanza quando possibile. Puoi applicare una sequenza di gate di swap tra qubit vicini per spostare le informazioni del qubit
in giro, ma i gate di swap sono costosi e soggetti a errori, quindi potrebbero esserci modi migliori per farlo. Poi, il layout
WEBVTT
e l'instradamento sono processi iterativi e assegnano un qubit virtuale del tuo circuit al qubit fisico sull'
hardware. Puoi farlo a mano, ma ci sono anche strumenti in Qiskit che possono fare raccomandazioni per il layout del
qubit fisico basate su tassi di errore approssimativi. Poi possiamo comporre sequenze di gate a singolo qubit che agiscono sullo stesso qubit
in gate singoli e a volte possiamo anche eliminare gate non necessari o combinazioni di gate. Ad esempio,
alcune combinazioni di gate possono essere ridotte a combinazioni più semplici e a volte combinazioni di gate equivalgono addirittura
semplicemente a un operatore identità, quindi possiamo semplicemente eliminarle. Puoi farlo automaticamente usando il
Qiskit transpiler, oppure puoi farlo manualmente gate per gate se hai una buona ragione per farlo e vuoi
più controllo. Una volta migliorato il layout del circuit, l'instradamento e i conteggi dei gate, sia a mano che usando il Qiskit transpiler,
di solito vogliamo visualizzare il nostro circuit per assicurarci che la temporizzazione di tutti i gate abbia senso. C'è un argomento che puoi impostare nel transpiler per
visualizzare la linea temporale del tuo circuit e assicurarti che tutto sia allineato nel modo che ti aspetti. Ora parliamo della soppressione degli errori.
La soppressione degli errori si riferisce a varie tecniche che trasformano un circuit durante la compilazione per minimizzare gli errori.
È diversa dalla mitigazione degli errori, che avviene dopo che il circuit è già stato eseguito, di cui parleremo a breve. Le due forme più comuni di
soppressione degli errori di cui ci avvaliamo sono il dynamical decoupling e il Pauli twirling. Ci saranno alcuni
dettagli tecnici qui, ma puoi sempre fare riferimento a questo più tardi. Quindi il primo: il dynamical decoupling viene usato per
annullare efficacemente parte del rumore che influenza il qubit applicando una serie di gate che insieme ammontano all'
operazione identità, come sequenze XX, il cui effetto netto è di annullare approssimativamente i canali di rumore che influenzano
il qubit. Il Pauli twirling è un modo per inserire gate casuali per semplificare il rumore medio. La casualità aiuta
a prevenire che gli effetti di diversi errori si accumulino così velocemente e rende anche il rumore più facile da caratterizzare.
Ora, questo metodo forma anche la base di una tecnica di mitigazione degli errori, di cui parleremo più avanti.
Di nuovo, c'è molte informazioni qui e non preoccuparti se non si assimila tutto subito. Per fortuna, molto di questo può essere fatto automaticamente usando il Qiskit
transpiler. La transpilazione può essere complicata, ma la transpilazione è un passo così cruciale per raggiungere l'utilità su scala
che richiede molta prova ed errore per essere padroneggiata e ottenere i migliori risultati. Ora voglio fare una breve
pausa per discutere il Qiskit transpiler e le sue capacità un po' più in dettaglio. Lo farò ad un livello molto alto e vedremo i
dettagli con alcuni esempi più avanti. In generale, la transpilazione è il processo di riscrittura di un dato circuit in input per adattarsi alla
topologia del dispositivo quantistico specifico e ottimizzare il circuit per l'esecuzione e la resilienza contro il rumore. Riscrive anche
un dato circuit nei gate base di quel processore quantistico specifico che hai selezionato. Qiskit ha quattro
pipeline di transpilazione integrate e a meno che tu non abbia già familiarità con l'ottimizzazione dei quantum circuit, ti raccomando decisamente di usare una di quelle
pipeline integrate. Per impostazione predefinita, il transpiler include questi sei passi: inizializzazione,
layout, instradamento, traduzione, ottimizzazione e pianificazione. L'inizializzazione si riferisce a
qualsiasi passaggio iniziale richiesto prima di iniziare a incorporare il circuit sul backend. Questo in genere comporta
lo srotolamento delle istruzioni personalizzate e la conversione del circuit in soli gate a uno e due qubit. La fase di layout
applica una mappatura del layout dei qubit virtuali nel circuit ai qubit fisici su un backend. L'instradamento viene eseguito dopo che è stato applicato un layout
e inietta gate come gate di swap nel circuit originale per renderlo compatibile con la
connettività del backend. La quarta fase è la traduzione. In questa fase, i gate nel circuit vengono tradotti nel set di basi del
backend target. Poi c'è l'ottimizzazione. Questa fase esegue il ciclo di ottimizzazione principale
ripetutamente fino a quando non viene soddisfatta una condizione, come raggiungere una certa profondità target. Abbiamo quattro diversi livelli di ottimizzazione
tra cui scegliere. Ultimo è la pianificazione. Questa fase è per eventuali passaggi di pianificazione consapevoli dell'hardware. Ad alto livello, la pianificazione può essere intesa come
l'inserimento di ritardi nel circuit per tenere conto di eventuali tempi di inattività sui qubit
tra l'esecuzione delle istruzioni. Quindi, come ho detto, ci sono quattro livelli di ottimizzazione che vanno da 0 a 3, dove
livelli di ottimizzazione più alti richiedono più tempo e sforzo computazionale, ma potresti ottenere un circuit migliore.
Il livello di ottimizzazione zero è destinato agli esperimenti di caratterizzazione del dispositivo e come tale mappa solo il circuit in input ai
vincoli del backend target. Non esegue alcuna ottimizzazione. Il livello di ottimizzazione tre
spende il massimo sforzo per ottimizzare il circuit. Tuttavia, poiché molte delle tecniche di ottimizzazione nel
transpiler si basano su euristiche, spendere più sforzo computazionale non porta sempre a un miglioramento
nella qualità del circuit in uscita. Se questo ti interessa ulteriormente, controlla le pagine del transpiler nella
documentazione di Qiskit collegata qui sotto. Ora siamo pronti a discutere l'esecuzione effettiva di un quantum circuit.
Le Primitive di Qiskit Runtime forniscono un'interfaccia all'hardware IBM Quantum e astraggono anche la
soppressione e mitigazione degli errori dall'utente. La primitiva sampler restituisce la distribuzione di quasi-probabilità o i conteggi
che rappresentano la probabilità di misurare certe stringhe di bit, zeri e uni. La primitiva estimator restituisce i valori di aspettativa
degli osservabili corrispondenti a quantità fisiche. Quindi, con un po' più di dettaglio, il sampler esegue il circuit
più volte su un dispositivo quantistico, eseguendo misurazioni a ogni esecuzione e costruendo la distribuzione di probabilità
dal recupero di quelle stringhe di bit. Più esecuzioni o shots esegue, più accurati saranno i risultati,
ma questo richiede più tempo. Le risorse quantistiche necessarie per eseguirlo. Nello specifico, calcola la
probabilità di ottenere ogni possibile stato della base standard misurando lo stato preparato dal circuit. L'
estimator di Qiskit usa un processo algebrico complesso per stimare il valore di aspettativa su un vero dispositivo quantistico,
scomponendo l'osservabile in una combinazione di altri osservabili che hanno basi proprie note e operando. Sotto il cofano delle Primitive ci sono le tecniche chiamate mitigazione degli errori. La mitigazione degli errori è un termine ombrello per tutto questo e
si riferisce fondamentalmente alle tecniche che ci consentono di ridurre gli errori del circuit modellando il rumore del dispositivo al momento della
esecuzione. In genere, ciò comporta un overhead di preprocessing quantistico legato all'addestramento del modello e un overhead di
post-processing classico per mitigare gli errori nei risultati grezzi usando un modello generato. Ma in cambio di questo
overhead, siamo in grado di ottenere risultati molto più accurati. Ci sono più tecniche che possiamo implementare per
la mitigazione degli errori e ne esamineremo tre in dettaglio. Sii consapevole però che questa è un'area di
WEBVTT
ricerca attiva, quindi nuove tecniche saranno probabilmente inventate e quelle più vecchie continueranno a essere migliorate. Il
livello di resilienza aumenta il costo, in altre parole il tempo necessario per eseguire il tuo job. Abbiamo già detto che al
livello di resilienza zero, il transpiler non fa nulla al tuo circuit, ma partendo dal livello di resilienza uno, introduce un metodo chiamato twirled
readout error extinction, o lo chiamiamo T-REX in breve. Twirled readout error extinction usa il Pauli twirling per
mitigare il rumore, qualcosa che abbiamo già menzionato. È una tecnica molto generale ed efficace che
intuitivamente rende il rumore meno irregolare e più facile da gestire. Partendo dal livello di resilienza due,
introduciamo la zero noise extrapolation o ZNE in breve. Questa è una tecnica popolare con cui abbiamo avuto recentemente molto
successo. L'idea alla base di ZNE potrebbe essere un po' sorprendente: aggiungiamo effettivamente del rumore aggiuntivo
in cima a quello già presente, ma quello che questo fa è permetterci di estrapolare nella direzione inversa per
prevedere come apparirebbero i risultati se ci fosse meno rumore. Questo può essere fatto in diversi modi specifici. Ad esempio,
possiamo allungare i gate per renderli più lunghi e quindi più soggetti a errori, oppure possiamo eseguire più gate che
risultano in un'operazione identità, quindi il circuit non cambia funzionalmente, ma campioniamo deliberatamente più
rumore. Devi farlo però per ogni circuit e ogni valore di aspettativa che vuoi tracciare, quindi
puoi vedere come può finire per essere molto costoso in termini di tempo richiesto. Un tipo specifico di ZNE si chiama
probabilistic error amplification, o PEA in breve. Una volta che abbiamo appreso un modello di rumore per un gate, PEA funziona campionando
errori da quel modello di rumore e iniettandoli deliberatamente nel circuit. Come ho menzionato, molte nuove
tecniche continuano a essere sviluppate e si spera vengano implementate man mano che ne vediamo apparire sempre di più. C'è solo un'ultima forma di
mitigazione degli errori che voglio discutere, chiamata probabilistic error cancellation. Invece di essere al terzo livello di resilienza,
PEC è una capacità speciale che devi attivare manualmente in Qiskit perché le risorse computazionali
necessarie non scalano molto bene rispetto alle altre tecniche di mitigazione degli errori di cui abbiamo parlato. Inizi
imparando il rumore che influenza il tuo circuit eseguendo circuit di apprendimento del rumore o di caratterizzazione del rumore
per ogni strato unico di gate a due qubit nel tuo circuit. Questi risultati ti permettono di descrivere il rumore
in termini di operatori di Pauli. Una volta noti questi termini di rumore, puoi modificare i tuoi circuit in modo
che abbiano effettivamente le PEC opposte incorporate per cancellare questi canali di rumore. In qualche modo questo processo è
simile a quello delle cuffie con cancellazione del rumore. Tuttavia, questo modo di annullare il rumore è molto costoso, con un tempo di
esecuzione che cresce esponenzialmente rapidamente con il numero di gate. Quindi potrebbe non essere la scelta migliore per un circuit molto grande.
Abbiamo ora raggiunto la fase finale: il postprocessing. Alla fine, se hai fatto un buon lavoro e impiegato le giuste tecniche di mitigazione degli errori,
potresti vedere la tua risposta finale spostarsi come in questa figura qui. Una distribuzione non mitigata
mostrata in viola è piuttosto lontana dal valore atteso reale mostrato qui da questa linea. Tuttavia, una volta che applichiamo la nostra
mitigazione degli errori, otteniamo una distribuzione mitigata mostrata qui in blu che ha il picco molto più vicino al valore reale.
Ora, tutto questo ha un costo e qui possiamo vedere che la varianza, o la larghezza della distribuzione, è aumentata, il che
non è generalmente ciò che vuoi, ma tutto ha un costo. Per fortuna, possiamo tenere conto di questo eseguendo più
shot, il che fa sì che la distribuzione si riduca a un livello accettabile di incertezza. Quindi è più o meno tutto per questa
lezione. Per la prossima volta, prenderemo tutti questi passi e li metteremo insieme e lavoreremo attraverso un'area e un esempio
di applicazione di interesse reale. Ci sono alcune cose che posso raccomandare di fare nel frattempo: se non l'hai ancora fatto,
assicurati di scaricare e configurare Qiskit 1.0. Puoi anche consultare la lezione associata a questo capitolo e
l'episodio precedente nella piattaforma IBM Quantum Learning. E infine, se hai interesse ad approfondire e
saperne di più sulle tecniche di mitigazione degli errori, consulta una delle numerose fonti che ho collegato qui sotto. A presto!
Ci vediamo la prossima volta.
[Musica]